Oh 2,800 bull yeah I could try should I
try I'll try cuz I'm close
here's what I'll do I mean just join the
one in the pool when I lose a game I
retire I play viewers so the goal is to
get to twenty hundred I'll be playing
probably slightly better players and I
was in the tournament that's just the
nature of joining a pool
okay maybe maybe not but I keep playing
until I lose some yeah so trans 2801
cause you or 2800 feet forward oh yeah
that's true
it's good point that's not mess up my
opening theory g6 that's a new move I
have this idea maybe a three and then
taken them this it's very close well the
Queen's being hugged apply all my pieces
how the Queen's safe now opponent
actually kind of knows theory here
fascinating
I like the position defend the pawn
there's ninety two we trade nights
okay.what sit down let's move back well
I didn't want to play that move but
that's okay
okay I'm gonna win a pawn maybe maybe no
it's okay I win a rook that's even
better
thank you to my opponents taking the
bishop this is prisons I'm down on time
though time to surf free-living oh
that's not neat
it's close enough okay let's go got the
meeting yeah so um I gained zero-rating
points for that that's it could take a
while to get to 2800 I think when it
says +0 it could be like plus a fraction
okay hopefully I gave me someone from
this high wind okay so we have some wine
what does this move put the bishop back
and g5 is kind of interesting
yeah cuz I'll have some some sort of
King side attack maybe wow what does
this move can take and rook g8 I think
like some trouble it spins everywhere
I can take here yeah life is good I'll
do challenges after I lose a bullet game
so oops I don't want to rematch I want
new opponents so yeah if you want to
root for me to lose mr. more than
welcome to
I'm not playing people my rating because
my ratings so ginormous but hopefully
I'll gain rating if I if I win this game
b6
yeah with b6 upon's con weak and there's
a trap with Bishop a6 to b7 it's very
hard to stop it should be southern the
rooks about to get trapped yeah black
can't really fight for the C file
because I always control c8 okay so
we'll trade
I wanna play bishop see it
that's a funny move attacking from
behind ooh i blunder it kind of a
blunder kind of hmm i have this move
it's a nifty move don't know if it does
much cuz Queen h4 r h4 g3 hmm it's
getting weird let's just take honey
puffs Junior sucks play this move yeah
I'm saving myself just have to say focus
it's not plunger clean okay got by there
Wow okay I gained two rating points
let's let's go to rating points at a
time so we have a Stafford gambit this
is a fun line I'm very fun behind Keaney
- I guess I can play this move I'm just
aligned with the king
Wow do I have anything maybe I don't
have much just play this move
like way it's kind of in a bind
I just want to castle somehow King f3
trying to confuse me
King g3 what is this play f5 what does
this position play g5 check check mate
that's checkmate house check me what a
weird game I was a really weird game hmm
it was so unusual kind of keen was just
dragged kind of willingly
it was willingly dragged okay let's play
someone new so I'm at 20 a little bit
2783 meets goo goo okay we have a
reverse whatever this is
yeah the pawns always happy on e5
there's attack on g4
okay so you have a kind of standard
position Knight c5 could hurt me okay
rook b8 wooden Knight takes b7 could
hurt me actually I'm not getting to hurt
here they work back defend the pawn the
knight wants to come to f4 and create
havoc in White's camp I want to take on
c5 you can't quite do that what to do g6
want to play f5
and Ricky ate eventually ooh free lights
thank you
am I scared
I'm kind of scared it's a soccer queen
yeah this should be good enough I've so
many pieces Oh opponent wants to
perpetual me or check me once there
check me twice
check me twice game over okay let's new
game oh man I feel like bad things are
about to happen playing a strong player
now let's go
Iman well Jimenez this could be the last
game or this could be a board game this
is yeah this is aborted
Oh playing ooh fastest man alive
this could be yeah this could be the end
of them my run but we'll see happy
thoughts happy thoughts London time we
haven't kind of a main line hmm that's a
good move or is it rook c1 is
surprisingly powerful so kind of wins a
pawn but maybe not and maybe not I want
to do this man g5 those may be a bad
move to start with I've kind of
committed myself to just attacking
that's kind of working take take here
and then I'm take here because I win the
bishop in the end or maybe I'm a it's
like there's a g6
it's a background fork
I don't play night c-5 next even that g5
fighting made into a queen sack fern oh
I can't do that
tricky tricky play this move again
threatening mates yeah black suit I
needed those nice rematch okay play my
garbage opening oh thanks for the bets
I'll wizard again hmm
I think I just want to triple up yeah a
tripling up time there's not enough one
could take a two maybe
and then digit e for
mmm it's kind of risky let's go for it
though
it's very risky I'm just trying to
confuse the opponents
yeah okay there we go cuz there's a pin
yeah so when g3 maybe maybe not
not if one was better
what does this move takes takes I think
this is winning because Bishop HP I'm
controlling each of this so the King
can't be useful
this better be a winning pawn and I'm
not upon that's kind of confusing though
c5 is a nice move and c4 pass pawn so I
have two passers let's go I think I'm
one game away okay we have a new opening
yeah at 392 king b1 this is all pretty
standard blocks not gonna Castle
kingside though that's a move nice move
good move play this move
I'm trying to do something on the
kingside hmm hopefully five maybe or a
five
what I do g4o this is terrified playing
the fastest man alive to have to open
the center
oh dear I don't see what to do here I'm
just getting me high do I play again I
feel like I should play again I'm so
close just like two wins away how hard
could it be
I'm sorry I'm gonna cold in if I lose
again I'm done and then we'll have an
episode - I just I'm really craving that
2,800 I'll take with a pawn
don't you see move and then put the
Queen here yeah the night belongs on e7
policy sex
interesting I could take I'm setting up
a trap now take side Bishop here I can
take that maybe not
play this move
to resent relies
it's not pleasant but it's playable
yeah this is a nice tactic attacking the
rook and the Knights defend
counter-attack I'm scared for my own
speed see how fast actually is so far
not too fast I'm feeling more
comfortable here let's go pretty much
okay
really getting pulled into this let's
play this opening again oh I like the
position earlier a slightly different
typical line oh this is a very pleasant
position a quinium one I think is uh I
go to middle okay I want to play G
folder probably might see one and I hear
h5 let's go just trying to attack in
this move of this move
it's a nice move
it takes some g5 I have this g5 let's go
okay just be safe they never make it
easy
Wow okay thankfully I have queen bee
AIDS okay
one more let's go okay this is nice this
is very nice a white fell for this trap
that's one of the most common sat for
gambit traps on f3 Queen g5 still
prepped
that's a new move don't play this move
I'm giving up c7 never mind I have six
bring the bishop back to d6
ooh I forgot about that
forgot about that - I'm so bad it's
still tricky tops of Corey bishops I
mean I might be meeting Wow
King yeah this is winning now let's not
mess this up
oh don't prep at me you don't protect me
please oh no stop it stop it stop stop
it stop it please just stop Oh No
let's go what a finish
well they finish then that's man
well the top looks ready game let's go
very laughing worthy game yeah I think
I'm retired for some bullets
it's what's my rating now also thanks
for the sub and thanks to the wizard man
Surya okay I gots to 2802 there are four
Queens on the board that's a very messy
finish
cuz I didn't see mates oh I had Queen
before oops okay I think that's more
YouTube content they're reaching my
highest ever bully rating that's so nice
okay thanks people for watching and bye
people you are the man oh thank you DT
yeah by people I mean on future YouTube
people but also twitch people future
YouTube people like the video comment
subscribe and I'll see you in the future